Professor Progressive activists and now
third party presidential candidate Dr
Cornell West is fighting against the
status quo it's a role he's very
familiar with Wes was born in Tulsa
Oklahoma he was raised in Sacramento
even before he finished high school he
became involved in the Civil Rights
Movement he attended organizing protests
he finished Harvard in just three years
graduating magna laude then he went
on to Princeton where he got his Masters
and his PhD
he's taught at Harvard at Yale and at
Princeton University
he made cameos in two Matrix films but
also put out a hip-hop album and he was
frequently a guest on this very show
having done all that he's now making a
run for the White House
I enter in the Quest for truth I entered
the Quest for justice and the presidency
is just one vehicle to pursue that truth
and Justice what I've been trying to do
all of my life
joining me now Dr Cornell West 2024
presidential candidate for the green
party Professor West it's great to see
you tonight it's really great to have
you back on the show the last time you
were here I think
it was as a 2020
Bernie Sanders surrogate so things have
changed a little bit so you know why do
you think so many of the I mean I was
laughing about that like Bernie Sanders
indeed no it seems like my dear brother
but but first I want to thank you for
having me on Sister Laura very much so
but no Bernie got shut down by the
corporate wing of the democratic part
and Democratic party is so tied to Wall
Street is so tied to the Pentagon that I
thought it very important to build on
the Richard Legacy that is shaped and
molded me not just the West family not
just Shiloh Baptist Church on the
charter side of Sacramento but the
legacy of the mall is the King's Union
Rabbi hetchel and Edward Zaid and
Dorothy Day and Grace Lee Boggs so it's
this Legacy spills over now into
electoral politics because I'm
thoroughly convinced my dear sister that
the two-party system stands in the way
for the empowerment of precious poor
people and precious working people and I
am fundamentally committed to the plight
of the Taste of these not just here and
around the world I'm against the
militarism abroad I'm against to
organize greed I'm against the rutinize
indifference to the vulnerable no matter
what color they are no matter what
gender no matter what sexual orientation
the Dr West I know you so you support
um drawing this Ukraine conflict to a
close and just tonight the Washington
Post is reporting that the Biden
Administration is giving backing to a
plan that would remove barriers
to Ukraine's entry into NATO without
setting a timeline for its admission so
the Democrat Party is obviously all in
as are many Republicans other not not
Donald Trump I don't think Ron DeSantis
but pretty much all the other
Republicans
are for the U.S being on the hook for
perpetually defending Ukraine from the
aggression of any other country why is
that interventionism let's focus on the
Democrat Party at the Cornerstone now of
who they are really in foreign policy
how did that happen and why
well I mean Democratic party is has a
long history of being committed to Wars
look at you can go back all the way to
Vietnam but unfortunately we have to
tell
truth NATO
the promise would be that NATO would not
move one inch against or toward Russian
territory a few years later 14 former
Soviet
country is part of NATO so you can
imagine any Empire the American Empire
the most powerful and it's you know the
history of invasion and occupation but
you would probably agree that if there
were Russian missiles in Mexico Russian
missiles in Canada it would be blown The
Smithereens very very quickly why
because Empires behave that way now if
you're a radical Democrat you you have a
critique of the Imperial
overlay of your country that includes
organized greed at the top with Wall
Street and it includes the War
profiteers I would say Cornell I'm in
solidarity with the suffering of the
Ukrainian people but we've got to bring
that war to a stop cease fire and then
proceed diplomatically and and transfer
some of those funds from the military to
investment in jobs and health care and
quality education and decent Dr West one
thing I'm very curious about because on
on these seminal issues like you and I
disagree on a lot but you and I actually
agree on a lot we on the surveillance
date on on the Perpetual war on the Wall
Street influence and politics we agree
on a lot of things to me it seems like
you're closer in many ways
to to populist conservatives on those
types of issues then you are the the
modern Democrat Party and I know you're
running as a green
but can't you tonight say that Donald
Trump did more
for African Americans in the inner city
with increased uh real median income
increased of entrepreneurial
opportunities Criminal Justice Reform
all the things that he did when he was
president given all the investigations
all the stuff that was happening
can't you recognize that he actually was
doing his best at the time to stand up
for disenfranchised people with an
economy that was actually growing for
the first time for real median income
was growing for all demographic groups
but
but you have to acknowledge that the
grotesque wealth inequality was
increasing even as those low
unemployment rates were in place not
giving credit for the low unemployment
rate but the problem with brother Trump
is it's very important to keep in mind
you know we got to do away with all this
hatred and revenge I don't hate brother
Trump I hate the lies and I hate the
gangster activity and I hate the kind of
neofascial language he uses when he
trashes Muslims when he trashes calls
Black Folk football players sons of
b-i-t-ca no his language was his
neo-fascist and he was still tied to Big
military still allowing Wall Street to
get away that's that's where you and I
would disagree that's where that's what
we did but I'll say this
um
but I hate Biden's hypocrisy
yeah but the surveillance state has the
surveillance state that you and I and I
think a lot of conservatives have grown
incredibly mistrustful of and the
outside of the Pentagon they were all
turned against Trump so we you have to
acknowledge that Millie the whole
million yeah
against Trump all of them why were they
against Trump if he was a big threat
it's because of that neo-liberal
apparatus wanted to retain its status
and Trump came in as a Critic from the
right wing right and that's where the
neo-fascism comes in by trashing the
immigrants trashing too many precious
gay brothers
and even the people's support but I can
tell you this as a presidential
candidate I'm going straight into
brother Trump's country and I'm going to
tell the brothers and sisters of all
colors I want you not to scapegoat the
most vulnerable I want you to confront
the most powerful that's Wall Street
that's Silicon Valley that's the war
problems
they're going to hate you they're going
to hate you and they're going to hate
you all right I I welcome I welcome
but
yeah I want to ask you about an open
border I mean take it away from Trump
the border is essentially open today if
you want to come into the country you
can come in which the Liberals have all
said they're always for they like the
idea of an open border do you think an
open border has helped the plight of
African Americans in cities like Chicago
in New York St Louis Baltimore Oakland
you know San Francisco has it helped
their standard of living
owning one is that you first always have
to begin at the top you have to look at
the ways in which the business people
and the property owners bring in cheap
labor in order to keep the wages low
that's why I support not your Trade
union movements that's why I support the
various strikes that's on the way this
summer to make sure working people gain
concessions because they sound like
Rhonda seem to be so greedy
no but no no but the problem with the
Santa says he's got disease
I will but I want the immigrants and the
workers of all colors to come together
against the bosses the Santa still has
too much xenophobia for me and that's
that's a radical difference between
right-wing populace and
highly left oriented people in love with
poor working people no matter what color
Cornell I think that and may I call you
Cornell I always call you Dr white corn
absolutely absolutely do you think do
you think there are ways for for the uh
left-wing populace and the right wing or
conservative populace can work together
on these issues where you where there is
Common Ground whether it's on the war
front there's no doubt about it there's
no there's comments about it my dear
brother Clifton West has said that what
we need is a paradigm shift in politics
what we need is an ideological
realignment of the of the landscape and
what that means with those who have
critiques of predatory capitalist
processes those who have critiques of
white supremacy you and I are going to
fight on divisions Legacy white
supremacy coming because the racism is
still operating not as intense as it was
75 years ago but it's still there in so
many different ways I think of what's
happening right now with my two dear
brothers in in Mississippi but so they
we have to but also I don't downplay The
Vicious attacks on my gay brothers and
lesbian sisters and trans and to defends
a women and women having control over
their bodies and Reproductive Rights
I don't know your review on Cornell is
your view on
trans athletes in women's sports because
you are a big champion of women we
disagree on the abortion issue but you
are a big champion of women and I
appreciate that I was a female athlete
my day ages ago
um but what about this yes do you think
trans men who are biological men should
like be in the Wimbledon finals
you know I mean I am committed to the
Dignity of precious trans folk because
they're so vulnerable and I just women
women don't have a shot then an attacked
no but no but but I'm also willing to
learn and listen in the argument because
I think it depends on case the case in
context to context I just want to make
sure that the most vulnerable are never
ever women are vulnerable yeah women are
vulnerable if they're competing against
women all right Dr West come back but
that's a delegation but we'll come back
thank you so much
all right you take care work together
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else